[Music]
goodbye so we have a ball Market coming
in less than a year I know I'm so
excited I need one I've lost all my
money I'm broke yeah you're losing your
money as
shitcoins so we have a bll market coming
in less than a year and every cycle they
keep telling us the exact same thing
they make you think that this time is
going to be different they literally
told us this at the top of the bull
market in November 2021 how what did
they say to us they told us that this
time is different we're going to see a
super cycle super cycle and we never saw
a super cycle and then people like you
start taking out crazy leverage going
long at the top of theet don't don't
tell them don't tell them what I did
please because your favorite Twitter
influencer told you that this time is
different and we're going to have a
super cycle based on what we literally
just had uh two years of lockdown and
precedented about amounts of money
printing where all of that money flew
into Bitcoin it propped up the entire
crypto market and of course a stock
market and then naturally the only next
step is not a super cycle it's inflation
where people have to start tightening
their pockets VCS can't be spending
money retail investors don't be spending
money because we have inflation so what
super cycle so why are they telling us a
super cycle what did they do to me when
I took out 100x leverage on Bitcoin in
November 2022 ready to go [__] long
they want you to be exit liquidity that
is why they tell you this time is
different this time is not different
we're going to have the Haring then
please God we're going to have a
beautiful 18-month bull market need that
and then everything is going to zero
your shitcoin is going to zero all your
altcoins are going to zero and Bitcoin
is going to pull back around 80% like it
does every single time take profit at
the top of the market so some of you
will then ask when do I take profit of
course at the top of the market but I'm
actually going to be letting you know
when I buy and when I sell in my private
telegram group I'm going to let you know
exactly what I'm doing so you can follow
along check it out and just be careful
cuz it's never any different 18 months
and then it and then it crashes